Step inside the shadowy world of the 1990s music industry with the Dragonfly, Brett Cantor murder mystery. In the latest original series from Case File Presents, we go behind the Velvet Roaps to explore the dark side of Hollywood's 90s club scene. In this world, secrets traded hands like currency. One of its most compelling and enduring mysteries is, who killed Brett Cantor. At just 25 years old, Music Label executive Brett Cantor had already built an impressive career at Chrysler's Music Group. He was instrumental in helping discover bands like Rage Against
走进1990年代音乐产业的阴暗世界，探索布雷特·坎特（Brett Cantor）谋杀之谜。在《Case File Presents》的最新原创系列中，我们将深入“天鹅绒绳索”背后，探索好莱坞90年代俱乐部场景的阴暗面。在这个世界里，秘密像货币一样被交易。其中最引人入胜且经久不衰的谜团之一是：谁杀了布雷特·坎特。年仅25岁的音乐厂牌高管布雷特·坎特已经在克莱斯勒音乐集团（Chrysler's Music Group）建立了一番令人瞩目的事业。他在发掘像“暴力反抗”（Rage Against）这样的乐队方面发挥了重要作用。
the Machine. By mid to 1993, Brett was at the top of his game, dating actress Rose McGowan and signing on as a partner in a popular Hollywood nightclub called Dragonfly. But then, on July 30th of that year, Brett was killed in his West Hollywood apartment. The murder sent shockwaves throughout the entertainment industry. Today, nearly 30 years later, the case remains unsolved. True Crime writer and podcast producer Jason Nova has spent three years investigating Brett Cantor's life and tragic death. In Dragonfly, Brett Cantor murder mystery, she reveals what her team has discovered and
the Machine（机器之怒）。到1993年中期，布雷特正处于事业巅峰，与女演员罗斯·麦高恩（Rose McGowan）约会，并签约成为好莱坞一家名为“蜻蜓”（Dragonfly）的知名夜店的合伙人。然而，那年的7月30日，布雷特在西好莱坞的公寓中遇害。这起谋杀案在整个娱乐界引起了轩然大波。如今，近30年过去了，案件仍未侦破。真实犯罪作家兼播客制作人杰森·诺瓦（Jason Nova）花了三年时间调查布雷特·坎特的生平及其悲剧性的死亡。在《蜻蜓：布雷特·坎特谋杀之谜》中，她揭示了她的团队所发现的内容，并
shares the haunting aftermath that documented by Brett's family and friends. This is one rock and roll true crime story you will never forget. Dragonfly, Brett Cantor murder mystery is out now wherever you get your podcasts. Stay tuned until the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often-distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The morning of Tuesday, September 1, 2015, started out like any other for Lieutenant Charles
分享了布雷特的家人和朋友所记录下的令人心碎的余波。这是一个你永远不会忘记的摇滚真实犯罪故事。《蜻蜓：布雷特·坎特谋杀之谜》现已在各大播客平台上线。请收听至今日节目的最后以获取预告片。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本节目的节目说明。2015年9月1日，星期二的早晨，对于查尔斯（Charles）中尉来说，
Joseph Glinnerwitz. The 52-year-old, who went went by Joe climbed into his squad car and began making his way towards the Fox Lake Community Centre in Northern Illinois. Joe had important business to attend to. He ran a program called the Fox Lake Explorers, which was a collaboration between the Boy Scouts of America and the Fox Lake Police Department. A guide towards 14 to 21-year-olds, the explorers gave youths who had an interest in law enforcement hands on experience with the different aspects of policing. The young men and women who trained under Joe's guidance were educated on everything from traffic stops to safe firearm use to crime scene investigation. And who better to teach them than Joe Glinnerwitz? A 30-year veteran of the force,
约瑟夫·格林诺维茨（Joseph Glinnerwitz）的早晨和往常一样。这位52岁、大家都叫他乔（Joe）的警官坐进警车，开始前往伊利诺伊州北部的福克斯湖（Fox Lake）社区中心。乔有重要的工作要处理。他负责一个名为“福克斯湖探险者”（Fox Lake Explorers）的项目，这是美国童子军与福克斯湖警察局之间的合作项目。作为14至21岁青少年的向导，探险者项目为那些对执法感兴趣的年轻人提供了关于警务不同方面的实践经验。在乔的指导下受训的年轻男女学习了从交通拦截到安全使用枪支，再到犯罪现场调查的所有知识。还有谁比乔·格林诺维茨更适合教他们呢？作为一名拥有30年警龄的资深警官，
Joe had dedicated his entire life to law enforcement. After leaving high school, he spent four years in the United States Army before rising through the ranks within the Fox Lake Police Department. He took on every role available, from K-9 Officer, to member of the SWAT team. He continued to serve in the Army reserves, amassing a long list of military and department medals. But for all his achievements, Joe's biggest source of pride was his work with the explorers.
乔将他的一生都奉献给了执法事业。高中毕业后，他在美国陆军服役了四年，随后在福克斯湖警察局一路晋升。他担任过所有可能的职务，从警犬队警官到特警队（SWAT）成员。他继续在陆军预备役服役，积累了长长的一串军事和部门奖章。但尽管成就斐然，乔最大的骄傲还是他与探险者们的工作。
Within a year of taking over the post in 1987, Joe had turned the program into something special. His trainees revered him. If you were in Joe's squad, you were considered a badass. Joe had recently been tasked with completing an inventory of all the explorers assets. He headed to the post to get an early start, making a quick stop at a gas station at around 7.05 am. Despite being fit and strong, Joe was also a heavy smoker, and he always kept two packs of cigarettes tucked
1987年接手该职位后的一年内，乔就将这个项目变成了一项特别的事业。他的学员们非常崇拜他。如果你在乔的队伍里，你就会被认为是个硬汉。乔最近被指派完成所有探险者资产的盘点工作。他前往岗位准备早点开始，并在早上7点05分左右在加油站快速停留了一下。尽管身体强壮，但乔也是个老烟枪，他总是把两包香烟塞在
in his car's sun visor. He stocked up his supply and resumed his journey. But as Joe made his way to the post, he took a detour past Honing Road, a rural stretch approximately one and a half miles from the community center. At 7.52am, he picked up his police radio and contacted Dispatch to report some suspicious activity. Joe told the operator, I'm going to be out at the old concrete plant checking on two males, whites, one male black.
车里的遮阳板里。他补充了补给，继续他的旅程。但当乔前往岗位时，他绕道经过了霍宁路（Honing Road），这是一段距离社区中心约1.5英里的乡村道路。早上7点52分，他拿起警用无线电联系调度中心，报告了一些可疑活动。乔告诉接线员：“我将在旧混凝土厂外查看两名白人男性和一名黑人男性。”
Although Joe wasn't technically yet on duty, there had been recent reports of vandalism in the area, and he had agreed to keep an eye on things. Besides, he was the kind of officer who considered himself on duty anytime he was in town. The dispatcher asked Joe if he needed backup. Joe responded. Negative at this time. Three minutes later, at 7.55am, Joe radioed in again.
虽然乔在技术上还没到上班时间，但该地区最近有破坏公物的报告，他已同意留意一下。此外，他是一个认为只要自己在城里就处于执勤状态的警官。调度员问乔是否需要增援。乔回答：“目前不需要。”三分钟后，即早上7点55分，乔再次通过无线电呼叫。
He told the dispatcher the man had taken off towards the swamp and he was pursuing them on foot. He gave his location as the gravel road that ran between the cement plant and honing road. Although he sounded cool and calm, the dispatcher once again asked if he wanted backup. This time Joe responded. Go ahead and send somebody. 3 police cars were quickly dispatched to the area, arriving on Hoening Road at 8.01am. Lieutenant Joe Glinnerwitz's squad car was parked near the old cement factory, but Joe himself was nowhere to be seen. The backup officers headed into the surrounding woods and battled their way through the marshy
他告诉调度员，这些人已经朝沼泽方向逃跑，他正在徒步追赶。他报告了自己的位置是水泥厂和霍宁路之间的碎石路。虽然他听起来冷静沉着，但调度员再次询问他是否需要增援。这次乔回答：“好吧，派人过来。”3辆警车迅速被派往该地区，于早上8点01分到达霍宁路。乔·格林诺维茨中尉的警车停在旧水泥厂附近，但乔本人却不见踪影。增援警官进入周围的树林，艰难地穿过沼泽
bog and thick scrub. The scrub was dense with green vegetation, making it near impossible to see through. The dispatcher radioed a joe asking for his current status. There was no response. They radioed for a second time. Still nothing. The dispatcher asked the other officers, Fox Lake units on honing,
和茂密的灌木丛。灌木丛中长满了绿色植被，几乎无法看穿。调度员通过无线电呼叫乔，询问他的当前状态。没有回应。他们第二次呼叫。依然没有回应。调度员询问其他警官：“福克斯湖的单位在霍宁路，
check status on 6740. One officer responded, we don't have him right now, we're looking for him. Suddenly, a loud bang rang through the air. There was no mistaking the sound. It was a gunshot. The officers charged further into the woods towards the swamp, trying to follow the direction of the noise. The dispatcher continually tried to radio Joe, but to no avail. Calls were placed to Joe's cell phone, but those two weren't unanswered.
检查6740的状态。”一名警官回答：“我们现在没看到他，我们正在找他。”突然，一声巨响在空中响起。那声音毫无疑问。那是枪声。警官们冲进树林，朝着沼泽方向跑去，试图跟随声音的方向。调度员不断尝试通过无线电呼叫乔，但无济于事。他们拨打了乔的手机，但也无人接听。
The minutes ticked by as the officers battled onwards. Then, at 809, one officer pushed to their way through the scrub and came to the bank of the swamp. A little further into the woods, lying face down, was the body of Joe Glenowicz. The officer rolled him over. Blood was coming from his nose and seeping out from above his collar. The officer radioed the dispatcher announcing, to the dispatcher announcing, Officer Down. It was a devastating sight for the first responding officers. One in particular became overwhelmed with emotion,
随着时间一分一秒过去，警官们继续艰难前行。然后，在8点09分，一名警官穿过灌木丛，来到了沼泽岸边。在树林深处，乔·格林诺维茨的尸体面朝下躺着。警官将他翻了过来。血从他的鼻子里流出，并从他的衣领上方渗出。警官通过无线电向调度员宣布：“警官倒下。”这对第一批赶到的警官来说是一个毁灭性的景象。其中一人特别情绪失控，
touching Joe's hand and wailing. Why Joe? Why Joe? No, no, no. Another said, he's gone. Get your gun out and call out anything you see. Joe Glenowicz had been shot twice. The first bullet struck him in the right hip where he kept his mobile phone. Joe was wearing a ballistic vest which prevented the bullet from entering his body, but his luck stopped there.
摸着乔的手哭喊道：“为什么是乔？为什么是乔？不，不，不。”另一人说：“他走了。拔出你的枪，呼叫你看到的任何东西。”乔·格林诺维茨被击中了两枪。第一颗子弹击中了他的右臀部，那里放着他的手机。乔穿着防弹背心，这阻止了子弹进入他的身体，但他的运气到此为止了。
The second bullet had been shot downwards into Joe's vest, striking him in the chest and penetrating his pulmonary artery. Such an injury meant he would have bled to death within minutes. Evidence at the scene indicated a struggle had taken place. Scattered around the ground were several of Joe's belongings, including his pepper spray, with its safety tab removed. A little further away, lay Joe's baton and glasses. Two shell casings were also recovered a short distance apart.
第二颗子弹向下射入乔的背心，击中了他的胸部并穿透了他的肺动脉。这样的伤势意味着他会在几分钟内失血过多而死。现场的证据表明发生过搏斗。乔的几件物品散落在地上，包括他的胡椒喷雾，其安全扣已被取下。再远一点的地方，躺着乔的警棍和眼镜。两枚弹壳也被发现，彼此相距不远。
This meant the gunshots had been fired from two different locations within the crime scene. The shell casings matched the 40 caliber service pistol carried by Joe Glynowitz. However, his holster was empty, and the pistol itself was nowhere to be seen. This raised the harrowing probability that the man Joe had been pursuing were now on the run with his stolen gun. A police bulletin immediately went out, warning that the trio were armed and dangerous. Four hundred heavily armed officers from across Illinois sped towards Fox Lake, a small village of less than 11,000 residents.
这意味着枪声是从犯罪现场内的两个不同位置发射的。弹壳与乔·格林诺维茨携带的40口径制式手枪相匹配。然而，他的枪套是空的，手枪本身也不见了。这引发了一个令人毛骨悚然的可能性：乔一直在追捕的人现在正带着他被偷的枪潜逃。警方立即发布公告，警告这三人携带武器且极其危险。来自伊利诺伊州各地的四百名全副武装的警官迅速赶往福克斯湖，这是一个居民不到11,000人的小村庄。
They sealed off the two square mile radius surrounding the crime scene, focusing the hunt for the shooters within. It wasn't an easy place to search. The designated Killzone consisted of heavily wooded areas, waterways, homes and businesses. It was also a hot day and the swampy landscape had generated harsh humidity. Officers wearing heavy tactical gear and carrying rifles began passing out from the heat. But investigators were taking no chances. Joe Glynawitz was the first officer to be fatally shot in the line of duty in Lake County
他们封锁了犯罪现场周围两平方英里的区域，将搜捕重点集中在内部。这不是一个容易搜查的地方。指定的“杀戮区”由茂密的树林、水道、住宅和企业组成。那天天气炎热，沼泽地带产生了强烈的湿气。穿着沉重战术装备并携带步枪的警官们开始因高温而晕倒。但调查人员不敢掉以轻心。乔·格林诺维茨是莱克县自1980年以来
since 1980, and the first ever to be killed in Fox Lake. Furthermore, the Labor Day long weekend was just four days away, a holiday that attracted thousands of tourists to the area. The Labor Day long weekend was just four days away, a holiday that attracted thousands of tourists to the area. Apprehending those responsible was of the highest priority. A SWAT team and 45 K9 units were brought in, while five helicopters and a fixed-wing aeroplane searched overhead. Some businesses were closed while schools were put on lockdown.
第一位在执行公务时被枪杀的警官，也是福克斯湖有史以来第一位被杀的警官。此外，劳动节长周末仅剩四天，这是一个吸引数千名游客到该地区的假期。劳动节长周末仅剩四天，这是一个吸引数千名游客到该地区的假期。抓获肇事者是重中之重。一支特警队和45个警犬小组被调来，同时五架直升机和一架固定翼飞机在空中搜寻。一些企业关闭，学校被封锁。
The local trains were stopped and residents were urged to stay indoors. One sniffer dog successfully picked up a sands. It was followed until the sands was lost with no discoveries. Word of what happened spread quickly in the close-knit community. Lieutenant Joe Glinnerwitz was somewhat of a local celebrity, known for his trademark outfit consisting of fatigues, combat boots and military hat. Combined with his tattooed muscley arms and tough persona, he learned the nickname of GI Joe. Residents were shocked to learn that GI Joe of all people had been gunned down.
当地火车停运，居民被敦促留在室内。一只嗅探犬成功捕捉到了一丝气味。它一直追踪，直到气味消失，没有任何发现。发生的事情的消息在这个紧密的社区中迅速传开。乔·格林诺维茨中尉在某种程度上是一位当地名人，以其标志性的装束而闻名，包括迷彩服、作战靴和军帽。加上他纹身的肌肉发达的手臂和强硬的形象，他赢得了“GI乔”的绰号。居民们震惊地得知，GI乔竟然被枪杀了。
But none were as shocked as Melody Cleanowitz, Joe's wife of 26 years. When she was delivered to the news by Mayor Donnie Schmidt, Melody collapsed and became physically ill. Meshmit told CNN, The way all that went out of her mouth then, will stay with me forever. The man hunt for Joe's killers intensified. All investigators had to go by was the vague description Joe had given the dispatcher, two white men, and one black. This made it near impossible to narrow down the suspect pool.
但没有人比梅洛迪·格林诺维茨（Melody Cleanowitz）更震惊了，她是乔结婚26年的妻子。当唐尼·施密特（Donnie Schmidt）市长将这个消息告诉她时，梅洛迪崩溃了，身体变得虚弱。施密特告诉CNN：“她当时发出的那种声音，将永远留在我的记忆中。”对乔的杀手的搜捕行动加剧了。调查人员所掌握的只有乔给调度员的模糊描述：两名白人男子和一名黑人男子。这使得缩小嫌疑人范围几乎是不可能的。
One call came through from a concerned citizen who reported that they'd seen the three suspects loitering near the treatment plant. Another became suspicious when they saw an unknown man running into a vehicle. Other calls came through, with locals eager to help in any way they could, but nothing emerged that identified the shooters. With no arrests made by Nightfall, helicopters fitted with thermal cameras flew overhead. Police obtained dashcam footage from a truck driver who was in the area around the time of the shooting, as well as recordings from traffic cameras and security footage from
一位忧心忡忡的市民打来电话，报告说他们看到三名嫌疑人在处理厂附近徘徊。另一人看到一名身份不明的男子跑向一辆车时产生了怀疑。其他电话也打进来了，当地人渴望以任何方式提供帮助，但没有发现任何能识别枪手的信息。随着夜幕降临仍未逮捕任何人，装有热成像摄像头的直升机在空中飞行。警方获得了当时在现场的一名卡车司机的行车记录仪录像，以及交通摄像头的录音和来自
a local homeowner. The footage was examined, but no immediate leads emerged. The search resumed at first light on Wednesday morning. Schools in the district remained closed as a safety precaution, but with the thermal scan as failing to detect anything, it was deemed unlikely that the killers were still in the area. The search expanded beyond the two-mile kill zone, with investigators turning their focus to tip-offs, while they waited for forensic analysis of the crime scene.
当地房主的监控录像。录像经过检查，但没有出现直接线索。搜查在周三早上第一缕曙光中恢复。该地区的学校作为预防措施继续关闭，但由于热成像扫描未能检测到任何东西，人们认为杀手仍在该地区的可能性不大。搜查范围扩大到两英里杀戮区之外，调查人员将重点转向举报，同时等待犯罪现场的法医分析。
The commander of Lake County's Major Crimes Task Force, George Falanco, fronted a press conference appealing for help from the public to catch the shooters, whom he described as extremely dangerous. He urged residents to remain vigilant, saying, All that takes is one tip or one good lead to break a case wide open. Falenco made it clear that the manhunt would continue until Joe's killers were apprehended, stating, I have a murdered colleague, a police officer, and we're not going to stop.
莱克县重大犯罪特别工作组指挥官乔治·法兰科（George Falanco）举行了新闻发布会，呼吁公众提供帮助以抓捕枪手，他称这些人“极其危险”。他敦促居民保持警惕，说：“只需要一个线索或一个好的线索就能彻底破案。”法兰科明确表示，搜捕行动将持续到乔的杀手被抓获为止，并声明：“我有一位被谋杀的同事，一名警官，我们不会停止。”
What investigators didn't reveal was that a significant piece of evidence had already been recovered. Within an hour of scouring the crime scene, a forensic examiner was scanning the ground about 2.5 feet from where Joe Glenowicz's body was found. There, lying in the tall grass between two trees, was Joe's gun. Analysis revealed the presence of DNA from someone other than Joe, giving investigators their first substantial clue. The Fox Lake community wasted no time in showing their support for the fall and officer. Many view to Joe Glinnerwitz's death as a sign of the increasing dangers faced by police.
调查人员没有透露的是，一件重要的证据已经被找回。在搜查犯罪现场的一小时内，一名法医正在扫描距离发现乔·格林诺维茨尸体约2.5英尺的地面。在那里，躺在两棵树之间的高草丛中，是乔的枪。分析显示存在除乔以外的其他人的DNA，这给了调查人员第一个实质性的线索。福克斯湖社区毫不犹豫地表达了对这位牺牲警官的支持。许多人将乔·格林诺维茨的死视为警察面临的危险日益增加的迹象。
Some were quick to blame the Black Lives Matter movement for encouraging citizens to fight out against excessive law enforcement. Mostly, residents simply couldn't comprehend that this had happened to an officer that many viewed as one of the best Fox Lake had ever seen. Members of the Explorer program were particularly troubled. Over the years, hundreds of youths who were trained by Joe went on to have successful careers in law enforcement or the military. Many of them viewed him as a mentor and father figure. One team told CNN that Joe's death felt like losing a family member.
一些人很快将矛头指向“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）运动，指责其鼓励公民对抗过度执法。大多数居民只是无法理解，这竟然发生在一个许多人视为福克斯湖有史以来最好的警官身上。探险者项目的成员尤其感到不安。多年来，数百名受乔训练的年轻人后来在执法部门或军队中取得了成功的职业生涯。他们中的许多人将他视为导师和父亲形象。一名队员告诉CNN，乔的死感觉就像失去了一位家庭成员。
As the search for Joe's killers escalated into a full-scale FBI investigation, a vigil was organized by village locals on the evening after the shooting. 1,200 people attended, with officers riding on horseback past mourners wielding handheld signs showing words of support, such as, police lives matter, and we stand with blue. Joe Glenowitz was remembered as an American hero. His wife Melody stood before the crowd, comforted by the couple's four adult sons, as she said through tears. four adult sons, as she said through tears. Joe was my best friend, my world, my hero. The love of my life for the last 26 and a half years.
随着对乔杀手的搜捕升级为全面的FBI调查，当地村民在枪击事件后的当晚组织了一场守夜活动。1,200人参加了活动，警官们骑马经过哀悼者，哀悼者们挥舞着手写标语，表达支持，例如“警察的命也是命”和“我们与蓝衣站在一起”。乔·格林诺维茨被铭记为美国英雄。他的妻子梅洛迪站在人群前，在他们四个成年儿子的安慰下，含泪说道：四个成年儿子，在泪水中说道：“乔是我最好的朋友，我的世界，我的英雄。过去26年半里我生命中的挚爱。”
He was the most wonderful caring and loving father to our boys. My world got a little bit smaller with his passing, and he will truly be missed by all of us. The former police chief Michael Bannon, who had spent 30 years working alongside the Joe, delivered a poem he wrote in his comrades' honor. A fallen hero, my friend in blue, strong and brave, his heart ever true, it read. A soldier and a policeman, he knew what it could cost. Tonight, a piece of America we have lost.
“他是我们孩子们最棒、最关心人、最慈爱的父亲。他的离去让我的世界变得小了一些，我们所有人都会真心怀念他。”曾与乔共事30年的前警察局长迈克尔·班农（Michael Bannon）朗诵了一首他为战友创作的诗。诗中写道：“一位倒下的英雄，我的蓝衣朋友，坚强而勇敢，他的心永远真诚。一位士兵和一名警察，他知道这可能付出的代价。今晚，我们失去了一部分美国。”
Later that evening at around 9.30pm, 30-year-old Nanny Kristen Keifer called police to report a bizarre incident. Kristen said she was driving down Route 12 in Volvo, a small village just five miles south of Fox Lake when she started experiencing car trouble. Kristen pulled over on the side of the road and stepped outside with a flashlight to see what was going on. Suddenly, two men wearing hoodies appeared out of nowhere. One was white and one was black. They asked Kristen if she was heading to Wisconsin
那天晚上晚些时候，大约9点30分，30岁的保姆克里斯汀·基弗（Kristen Keifer）打电话给警方报告了一起离奇事件。克里斯汀说，她正开车沿着福克斯湖以南仅五英里的沃洛（Volvo）小村庄的12号公路行驶时，车子出了故障。克里斯汀把车停在路边，拿着手电筒下车查看情况。突然，两名穿着连帽衫的男子凭空出现。一个是白人，一个是黑人。他们问克里斯汀是否要去威斯康星州
130 miles away and if they could get a ride. They then tried to steal her car. Kristen managed to jump back inside her vehicle and lock the doors. As she dialed 911, the two men fled into the cornfields at the back of a nearby garden center. For investigators on the Glenowitz case, this was a major breakthrough. Nearly 100 members of law enforcement quickly descended on the area, setting up a roadblock around the search perimeter. Thermally equipped helicopters scanned overhead as 11 K9 units aided the ground search. One dog soon picked up a scent.
（130英里外），问能不能搭便车。然后他们试图偷她的车。克里斯汀设法跳回车内并锁上了车门。当她拨打911时，两名男子逃进了附近一家园艺中心后面的玉米地。对于格林诺维茨案的调查人员来说，这是一个重大突破。近100名执法人员迅速赶到该地区，在搜查周边地区设置了路障。配备热成像仪的直升机在空中扫描，11个警犬小组协助地面搜查。一只狗很快捕捉到了气味。
It led offices through to the Volobog State natural area, a dense nature reserve containing woodland and open swamp land. But it didn't lead to the man. Instead, it turned out the canine had mistakenly tracked a deer. The helicopters also failed to detect any movement or heat sources. By 2.30am, no trace of the two men was found. Given how quickly investigators had acted, it seemed incredible that the men could have evaded detection, particularly given they were on foot.
它带领警官们穿过沃洛博格（Volobog）州立自然保护区，这是一个包含林地和开阔沼泽地的茂密自然保护区。但它并没有找到人。相反，事实证明警犬错误地追踪了一只鹿。直升机也未能检测到任何移动或热源。到凌晨2点30分，没有发现两名男子的任何踪迹。考虑到调查人员行动的迅速，这些人竟然能逃避侦查，尤其是考虑到他们是徒步，这简直令人难以置信。
Kristen Kepa was pressed for more information. She eventually admitted she made the entire story up in a bid to get attention from the family she worked for. Kristen was charged with disorderly conduct. She pleaded guilty, resulting in two years' probation, 250 hours of community service, and a restitution fine of $20,000 for the expenses incurred during the search. The Labor Day public holiday became a day of mourning, as thousands gathered in Fox Lake for Joe's funeral.
克里斯汀·基弗被要求提供更多信息。她最终承认，为了引起她所工作的家庭的注意，她编造了整个故事。克里斯汀被控扰乱治安罪。她认罪，结果被判处两年缓刑、250小时社区服务，并支付20,000美元的赔偿金，以支付搜查期间产生的费用。劳动节公共假期变成了一个哀悼日，数千人聚集在福克斯湖参加乔的葬礼。
A public viewing of his casket was held at a local high school before a five mile procession made up of over 1,000 police vehicles made its way through the streets lined with mourners. The governor ordered that all United States flags at government buildings be flown at half-mask until that evening. Speaking at his service, a friend and fellow officer said, When we were growing up, we all knew Joe was a hero, but now the nation knows he's a hero. Meanwhile, the locally based Motorola Solutions
他的灵柩在当地一所高中举行了公开瞻仰，随后由1,000多辆警车组成的五英里长的送葬队伍穿过街道，街道两旁挤满了哀悼者。州长下令政府大楼的所有美国国旗降半旗至当晚。在葬礼上，一位朋友兼同事警官说：“当我们成长时，我们都知道乔是英雄，但现在全国都知道他是英雄。”与此同时，总部位于当地的摩托罗拉解决方案（Motorola Solutions）
company offered a $50,000 reward for information that led to an arrest. FBI agents reviewed the various CCTV footage taken from the area on the day Joe Glinnerwitz was killed and identified three men matching the description of the ones the lieutenant was pursuing. A sequential video was pieced together and a search kicked off immediately to track the trio down. A-T-L was later, police found the man in question. The trio claimed they had nothing to do with the shooting and were reading breakfast at
公司悬赏50,000美元，以获取能导致逮捕的信息。FBI特工审查了乔·格林诺维茨被杀当天从该地区拍摄的各种监控录像，并确定了三名与中尉正在追捕的人描述相符的男子。一段连续的视频被拼凑起来，搜捕行动立即展开以追踪这三人。后来，警方找到了相关男子。这三人声称他们与枪击事件无关，当时正在
a nearby diner at the time. Investigators obtained footage, receipts, and witness statements to confirm this. With their alibi checking out and no other leads emerging, questions were raised about whether this could have been a targeted attack. Joe Glinnerwitz hadn't given the dispatcher any clear reason why he'd decided to pursue the three men out near Honing Road, or what exactly they'd done that he deemed suspicious. This raised the question, what if someone had a personal vent data against Jo and had lowered him out there? Analysis of the GPS unit in Jo's squadcar recorded him as arriving at the old cement factory at 7.25am.
附近的一家餐馆吃早餐。调查人员获得了录像、收据和证人陈述来证实这一点。随着他们的不在场证明得到证实，且没有出现其他线索，人们开始质疑这是否是一次有针对性的袭击。乔·格林诺维茨没有给调度员任何明确的理由，说明他为什么决定在霍宁路附近追捕这三名男子，或者他们到底做了什么让他认为可疑的事情。这引发了一个问题：如果有人对乔怀有个人恩怨并把他引诱到那里呢？乔警车上的GPS装置分析记录显示，他在早上7点25分到达了旧水泥厂。
The first call he'd placed over his police radio was at 7.52am. This meant he spanned almost 30 minutes in the area before contacting Dispatch, So what happened during that time? With all possibilities needing to be considered, investigators turned to Joe Kalinowitz's personnel file. The 264-page folder dated back to 1985. It was packed with accolades from business owners, civilians and members of numerous police departments commending Joe for his outstanding work during various incidents. Whether assisting in a serious criminal case or helping individuals out of a jam, he was praised for being professional, friendly and courteous. For the sensitive way Joe dealt with a victim's family, one police chief said,
他通过警用无线电发出的第一个呼叫是在早上7点52分。这意味着他在联系调度中心之前在现场待了近30分钟，那么这段时间发生了什么？由于需要考虑所有可能性，调查人员转向了乔·格林诺维茨的人事档案。这份264页的文件夹可以追溯到1985年。里面装满了来自企业主、平民和众多警察部门成员的赞誉，称赞乔在各种事件中的出色工作。无论是协助处理严重的刑事案件还是帮助个人摆脱困境，他都因专业、友好和礼貌而受到称赞。对于乔处理受害者家属的敏感方式，一位警察局长说：
compassion and understanding are not something that can be taught in a classroom, or learned in a textbook. One couple described the lengths Joe went to to help them when their car broke down, writing, ''Petrolman Glenowitz is a perfect example of a gentleman.'' But, as investigate has come through every page, it became clear that all was not as it seemed. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. The average break-in lasts 8-10 minutes, so fast response is crucial. That's why simply Safe Home Security launched its breakthrough technology 24-7 live
“同情心和理解力不是在课堂上能教出来的，也不是在教科书中能学到的。”一对夫妇描述了乔在他们车坏了时为帮助他们所做的努力，写道：“格林诺维茨警官是一位绅士的完美典范。”但是，随着调查人员翻阅每一页，很明显一切并不像看起来那样。Case File稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。平均入室盗窃持续8-10分钟，因此快速响应至关重要。这就是为什么SimplySafe家庭安全系统推出了其突破性的技术——24/7实时
guard protection to help stop crime in real time. Now, SimplySafe Professional Monitoring Agents can actually see, speak to and to deter intruders in your home through the new Smart Alarm Wireless Indoor Camera. SimplySafe Professional Monitoring Agents can now warn intruders that they are being recorded and police are on their way in real time stopping them in their tracks. The new Smart Alarm indoor camera is the only indoor security camera that can trigger the alarm and instantly deterring intruders with a built-in siren. With a advanced motion detection and vision AI,
监控保护，以帮助实时阻止犯罪。现在，SimplySafe专业监控代理可以通过新的智能报警无线室内摄像头，实际看到、对讲并威慑您家中的入侵者。SimplySafe专业监控代理现在可以实时警告入侵者他们正在被录像，警察正在赶来，从而阻止他们的行动。新的智能报警室内摄像头是唯一一款可以触发警报并利用内置警报器瞬间威慑入侵者的室内安全摄像头。凭借先进的运动检测和视觉AI，
the Smart Alarm Indoor camera can sense the difference between potential intruders and pets to reduce false alarms. 24-7 LiveGuard Protection and the new Smart Alarm Indoor camera works seamlessly as part of the entire Simply Safe Security system to keep your whole home safe from break-ins, buyers, flooding, and more. Right now, CaseFile listeners get a special 20% off any SimplySafe system when you sign up for a free month trial of fast-protect monitoring. This special offer is for a limited time only. Visit SimplySafe.com slash case file.
智能报警室内摄像头可以感知潜在入侵者和宠物之间的区别，以减少误报。24/7实时监控保护和新的智能报警室内摄像头作为整个SimplySafe安全系统的一部分无缝工作，以保护您的整个家庭免受入室盗窃、火灾、洪水等的侵害。现在，CaseFile听众在注册Fast-Protect监控的免费月度试用时，购买任何SimplySafe系统均可享受特别的20%折扣。此特别优惠仅限有限时间。访问SimplySafe.com/casefile。
That's simplysafe.com slash case file. There's no safe like simply safe. This episode of Case File is sponsored by BetterHelp. Sometimes in life we're faced with tough choices. Careers, relationships, or anything else. Nothing in life were faced with tough choices, careers, relationships, or anything else. Nothing in life stays constant. Things change, and the way forward isn't always clear and easy. Therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life, so
即SimplySafe.com/casefile。没有比SimplySafe更安全的地方了。本期CaseFile节目由BetterHelp赞助。有时在生活中，我们面临艰难的选择。职业、人际关系或其他任何事情。生活中没有什么是一成不变的。事情在变化，前进的道路并不总是清晰和容易的。治疗可以帮助您在驾驭生活时与您真正想要的东西保持联系，因此
you can move forward with confidence, clarity, and excitement. Trusting yourself to make decisions that align with your values is like anything, the more you practice, the easier it gets. At Case File, we know how important it is to look after your mental health and how difficult it can be to make decisions. That's why chatting with a therapist can be so beneficial. Someone who wants the best for you and can help you weigh up the pros and cons of any situation. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help at try. It's entirely online and flexible so it fits into your life.
您可以带着自信、清晰和兴奋前进。相信自己能做出符合您价值观的决定就像任何事情一样，练习得越多，就越容易。在CaseFile，我们知道照顾心理健康有多重要，做出决定有多困难。这就是为什么与治疗师聊天会非常有益。有人希望您好，并能帮助您权衡任何情况的利弊。如果您正在考虑开始治疗，请尝试BetterHelp。它完全在线且灵活，因此适合您的生活。
To get started, all you have to do is fill out a brief question air and you'll be matched with a licensed therapist, and you can switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Let therapy be your map with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash case file today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help, help.com slash case file. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. For all the praise he received, Lieutenant Joe Glenowitz's professional record was far from untarnished.
要开始，您只需填写一份简短的问卷，您就会被匹配到一位持证治疗师，并且您可以随时免费更换治疗师。让治疗成为您的地图，选择BetterHelp。今天访问betterhelp.com/casefile，您的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。即betterhelp.com/casefile。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。尽管他获得了所有赞誉，但乔·格林诺维茨中尉的职业记录远非完美无瑕。
Back in May of 1998, Alec County Sheriff's deputy was driving down Route 49 when they found a pickup truck idling on the side of the highway. Joe Glenowitz was behind the wheel, passed out drunk with his foot, pressed down on the accelerator. Oil was leaking from the engine. The deputy tried to wake Joe, but he wouldn't budge. It wasn't the first time something like this had happened. The deputy called a Fox Lake Police Detective who came to collect a Joe and organized to
早在1998年5月，莱克县警长副手正沿着49号公路行驶时，发现一辆皮卡车停在高速公路边怠速。乔·格林诺维茨坐在驾驶座上，醉得不省人事，脚踩在油门上。发动机正在漏油。副手试图叫醒乔，但他一动不动。这不是第一次发生这样的事情了。副手打电话给福克斯湖警察局的一名侦探，他来接乔并组织了
have his truck towed. The next morning, Joe couldn't remember a thing. Unable to recall where he left his truck, he reported at Stalin, only to learn the truth about what had happened. When questioned by his superiors, Joe claimed that he'd worked a long day before playing volleyball after his shift. He'd drunk six beers and several shots, causing him to black out. Several months later, Joe failed to report to work after a night out drinking, a decision that cost him
把他的卡车拖走。第二天早上，乔什么都不记得了。由于无法回忆起他把卡车停在哪里，他报告说车被偷了，结果才得知发生了什么事的真相。当被上级审问时，乔声称他在轮班后打排球前工作了很长一天。他喝了六瓶啤酒和几杯烈酒，导致他断片了。几个月后，乔在喝了一晚酒后未能按时上班，这个决定让他付出了
a two-day unpaid suspension. Joe admitted he had a drinking problem, but assured the police chief that he was handling it. The next few years were relatively uneventful, say for a few warnings about being late or failing to report for duty. Then in 2000, an officer named Denise was appointed to help Joe run the explorers post. Denise had joined the force in the 90s, making her the only woman in the all male Fox Lake PD. Denise loved her job, but before long, Joe began making her feel uncomfortable. He
两天的无薪停职。乔承认他有酗酒问题，但向警察局长保证他正在处理。接下来的几年相对平静，除了几次关于迟到或未能按时报到的警告。然后在2000年，一位名叫丹妮丝（Denise）的警官被任命协助乔管理探险者岗位。丹妮丝在90年代加入警队，使她成为全男性福克斯湖警察局中唯一的女性。丹妮丝热爱她的工作，但没过多久，乔就开始让她感到不舒服。他
demanded that she wear a tighter uniform and ordered that she accompany him to the bathroom while he urinated. On Valentine's Day of 2000, Joe told Denise to meet him at a hotel. There, he gave her a box of chocolates and began rubbing her shoulders. Joe allegedly told Denise there was a lieutenant on the squad who didn't like female officers. He offered to protect Denise and help her rise through the ranks on the condition that she provide him with sexual favors. Denise was a single mother who feared she'd lose her job if she didn't comply. Over the next eight months, she performed oral sex on Joe on five separate occasions, allegedly making it clear she didn't enjoy it.
要求她穿更紧身的制服，并命令她在小便时陪他去洗手间。2000年情人节，乔告诉丹妮丝在一家酒店见他。在那里，他给了她一盒巧克力，并开始揉她的肩膀。乔据称告诉丹妮丝，队里有一位中尉不喜欢女警官。他提出保护丹妮丝并帮助她晋升，条件是她提供性服务。丹妮丝是一位单身母亲，担心如果不服从就会丢掉工作。在接下来的八个月里，她被迫为乔口交了五次，据称她明确表示自己并不享受。
Denise eventually resigned from the explorers, no longer able to work under Joe Glinnerwitz, but she kept the details about his conduct to herself. In 2001, she attended a workshop about sexual harassment, after which she felt she could no longer remain silent. Denise told one of her superiors about Joe's behavior, and he was subsequently questioned about it. Joe admitted that the two had an inappropriate sexual relationship, but denied Deneese's claim of coercion.
丹妮丝最终辞去了探险者的工作，无法再在乔·格林诺维茨手下工作，但她把关于他行为的细节藏在心里。2001年，她参加了一个关于性骚扰的研讨会，之后她觉得不能再保持沉默了。丹妮丝告诉了她的一位上级关于乔的行为，随后他受到了质询。乔承认两人有不正当的性关系，但否认了丹妮丝关于强迫的说法。
He was suspended for 30 days, with the recommendation that he received counseling for sex addiction. But according to Denise, from that point on, she was put under constant scrutiny from her colleagues. She eventually quit her job and moved into state. Denise later told The New York Daily News, it was a good old boys' club if I didn't play along, then I was not going to stay. In 2005, Denise filed a lawsuit against the Fox Lake PD. It was ultimately thrown out when she failed to meet court requirements. Regardless, it cost the village tens of thousands of dollars in legal fees. Meanwhile, Joe
他被停职30天，并建议接受性瘾咨询。但据丹妮丝说，从那时起，她就受到了同事们的持续审查。她最终辞职并搬到了州外。丹妮丝后来告诉《纽约每日新闻》：“这是一个老男孩俱乐部，如果我不配合，我就待不下去。”2005年，丹妮丝对福克斯湖警察局提起诉讼。由于未能满足法院要求，诉讼最终被驳回。无论如何，这让村庄花费了数万美元的法律费用。与此同时，乔
Glenowicz continued to rise through the ranks and was eventually promoted from Sargent to Lutannand. Denise wasn't the only one imbedded by this. In 2009, the then mayor of Fox Lake, Cindy Irwin, received a two-page anonymous letter that started. Weed the members of the Fox Lake Police Department wish to inform you of certain situations which have occurred and require attention. The letter complained that morale within the department was at an all-time low,
格林诺维茨继续晋升，最终从警长晋升为中尉。丹妮丝并不是唯一一个被此困扰的人。2009年，时任福克斯湖市长辛迪·欧文（Cindy Irwin）收到了一封两页的匿名信，开头写道：“我们福克斯湖警察局的成员希望告知您一些已经发生并需要关注的情况。”信中抱怨说，部门内的士气处于历史最低点，
due in part to the ongoing, reprehensible misconduct by Lieutenant Joe Glinnerwitz. In addition to Denise's claims, a police dispatcher complained that Joe had sexually harassed and threatened her. Other personnel had seen Joe out and about with different women who weren't his wife. Various complaints had been made
部分原因是乔·格林诺维茨中尉持续的、应受谴责的不当行为。除了丹妮丝的指控外，一名警察调度员抱怨乔曾对她进行性骚扰和威胁。其他人员曾看到乔与除他妻子以外的不同女性外出。各种投诉已经由
by women who claimed Joe had inappropriately grouped their breasts during work Christmas parties. According to the letter, Joe's drinking was still an ongoing problem. Security guards at various establishments around the village had complained that Joe was becoming a nuisance and overstaying his welcome. There had been several instances where bouncers had to escort him out for being too intoxicated. He'd also allegedly failed to pay a bar tab of more than $300. Then there was the abuse of power. Joe had reportedly used a gift certificate that was donated to the police department to get a tattoo while on duty.
声称乔在工作圣诞派对期间不适当地摸过她们胸部的女性提出。根据这封信，乔的酗酒仍然是一个持续存在的问题。村里各场所的保安抱怨说乔成了一个麻烦，并且赖着不走。有几次保镖不得不因为他喝得太醉而把他赶出去。据称他还未能支付超过300美元的酒吧账单。然后是滥用职权。据报道，乔曾使用捐赠给警察局的礼券在执勤时纹身。
He'd also used his squad card to take his family on interstate holidays. As for the explorers, the letter complained that Joe was seriously bridging protocols. He'd given trainees unsupervised access to the police department, allowed them to operate department vehicles and permitted them to wear official garments that misrepresented them as actual police officers. According to the letter, complaints regarding these issues and many others had been made to the then chief of police, Michael Bayon, but nothing had been done. It was well known that Bayon and to Joe Glenowitz were close friends.
他还使用他的警车带家人去州际度假。至于探险者项目，信中抱怨乔严重违反了协议。他让学员在没有监督的情况下进入警察局，允许他们操作部门车辆，并允许他们穿上官方服装，这使他们被误认为是真正的警察。根据这封信，关于这些问题和许多其他问题的投诉已经向时任警察局长迈克尔·班农（Michael Bayon）提出，但什么也没做。众所周知，班农和乔·格林诺维茨是亲密的朋友。
The anonymous group concluded, chief Bayon's head in the sand attitude to dealing with lieutenant Glenowitz can no longer go on. It is our sincere hope that you will address this matter. We can no longer stand by and watch Lieutenant Glinnerwitz violate the rules and regulations, policies and procedures, and remain silent. If action wasn't taken, the group warned they'd have no choice but to contact the media, or escalate the issue to the relevant investigative agency.
匿名小组总结道：“班农局长对处理格林诺维茨中尉采取鸵鸟政策的态度不能再继续下去了。我们真诚地希望您能解决这个问题。我们不能再袖手旁观，看着格林诺维茨中尉违反规则、条例、政策和程序而保持沉默。”如果采取行动，该小组警告说，他们将别无选择，只能联系媒体，或将问题升级到相关的调查机构。
The discovery of this information left investigators scratching their heads. These records provided a stark contrast to the glowing reputation Joe Glinnerwitz had so far been memorialised for. It was also unexpected that an employee with such a blemished record would hold a lieutenant position. Mayor Donnie Schmidt, who considered Joe a close friend, was adamant that he was unaware of Joe's personal file. He said he'd never heard a single complaint against Joe in the two and a half years he'd served as mayor. But when investigators questioned other officers on Joe's squad, it quickly became apparent
这一信息的发现让调查人员感到困惑。这些记录与乔·格林诺维茨迄今为止被纪念的辉煌声誉形成了鲜明对比。一个有如此污点记录的员工能担任中尉职位也是出乎意料的。唐尼·施密特市长认为乔是亲密朋友，他坚称自己不知道乔的个人档案。他说，在他担任市长的两年半里，他从未听说过针对乔的任何投诉。但当调查人员询问乔队里的其他警官时，很快就显现出
that there were mixed feelings towards Joe Glenowicz. One of the female officers who had found Joe's body was aware of his history of sexual harassment. She claimed Joe once told her that he wasn't allowed to be alone with any of the police women. According to this officer, Joe was considered a golden child within the department. She believed he must have had some dirt on one of his colleagues to be allowed to stay on.
人们对乔·格林诺维茨的感情是复杂的。发现乔尸体的女警官之一知道他有性骚扰的历史。她声称乔曾经告诉她，他不被允许与任何女警察单独相处。据这位警官说，乔在部门内被认为是“金童”。她认为他一定掌握了同事的一些把柄，才被允许留下来。
With the Joe's unsavory history coming to light, it put extra weight on the possibility that he could have been killed by someone seeking vengeance. Investigators working the homicide case also had to consider whether Joe's death could have resulted from some other unknown secret. But there was another theory entirely. From the outset of the investigation, some questions had been raised about the crime scene. Despite the scattering of Joe's weapons, there were no other signs that a struggle had taken place.
随着乔不光彩的历史曝光，这增加了他可能被寻求报复的人杀害的可能性。负责这起凶杀案的调查人员还必须考虑乔的死是否是由其他未知的秘密导致的。但还有另一种完全不同的理论。从调查一开始，就有人对犯罪现场提出了一些疑问。尽管乔的武器散落一地，但没有其他迹象表明发生过搏斗。
Joe's clothing was in pristine order, other than a bit of mud on his pants. The heavily vegetated swampy area was also relatively undisturbed. Forensic examination had revealed that the fatal gunshot had been administered two inches under the top of Joe's bulletproof vest. Joe Glynawitz was a tough officer with decades of training in all matters of law enforcement. So how did a perpetrator get close enough to shoot him with his own gun without causing any other injuries, or at the very least, leaving Joe disheveled? There was also the question of why the shooter would leave Joe's gun at the scene. Why hadn't they taken it with them or disposed of it in the nearby swamp.
除了裤子上有一点泥土外，乔的衣着整洁如新。这片植被茂密的沼泽地也相对未受破坏。法医检查显示，致命的枪伤是在乔防弹背心顶部下方两英寸处造成的。乔·格林诺维茨（Joe Glynawitz）是一位经验丰富的警官，在执法各方面都有数十年的训练。那么，行凶者是如何在不造成任何其他伤害，或者至少没有让乔衣衫不整的情况下，近距离用他自己的枪射杀他的呢？还有一个问题是，为什么枪手会把乔的枪留在现场。他们为什么没有带走它，或者把它扔进附近的沼泽里。
The officer who had discovered Joe's body noted that Joe's hand had been tanced in a position that indicated he might have been holding a gun. These details, along with the mystery as to why Joe had been in the area for close to 30 minutes before calling the dispatcher, led to an uncomfortable question. Was it possible that the lieutenant had killed himself? Those close to Joe instantly shut this theory down. Joe was a larger than life character who had never shown any signs of depression or expressed the desire to self-harm.
发现乔尸体的警官注意到，乔的手呈现出一种姿势，表明他可能一直握着枪。这些细节，加上乔在呼叫调度员之前为何在该地区停留了近30分钟的谜团，引出了一个令人不安的问题。这位中尉有没有可能是自杀的？乔身边的人立即否认了这一理论。乔是一个性格开朗、充满活力的人，从未表现出任何抑郁迹象，也没有表达过自残的愿望。
Even the responding officer who had her own concerns about Joe's behavior denied the possibility. She told investigators that Joe was too vain to attempt suicide. What if he missed and ended up paralyzed for life? She didn't think Joe would risk it. Another officer who attended the scene wrote in their statement, there were no obvious signs or evidence to draw any conclusions, including suicide.
就连那位对乔的行为有自己担忧的响应警官也否认了这种可能性。她告诉调查人员，乔太爱面子了，不会尝试自杀。如果他没打中，导致终身瘫痪怎么办？她认为乔不会冒这个险。另一位在现场的警官在陈述中写道，没有明显的迹象或证据可以得出任何结论，包括自杀。
Forensic pathologists said there was nothing unusual about the tense positioning of Joe's hands. Hands can naturally curl up post-mortem, and there was nothing about the way Joe's hands were found that indicated suicide. The pathologist who performed a Joe's autopsy said it was highly unlikely that someone who was going to kill themselves would shoot themselves twice. Even though the bullet to the hip didn't penetrate his skin, it still would have been incredibly
法医病理学家表示，乔手部的紧张姿势并没有什么异常。死后手部会自然蜷缩，乔被发现时手部的姿势没有任何迹象表明是自杀。进行乔尸检的病理学家说，一个打算自杀的人开枪打自己两次的可能性极小。尽管击中臀部的子弹没有穿透他的皮肤，但它仍然会非常
painful. Some likened it to the same force as being hit with a sledgehammer. Also for skeptics of the suicide theory, if Joe had killed himself, how did his gun end up several feet away from his body? Furthermore, Joe had stocked up on his usual supply of cigarettes that morning. Why would he do that if he knew he wasn't going to be around to smoke them? On the Friday after Joe's death, the coroner's office received a call from a blocked number. The anonymous male caller claimed to be a retired Chicago police officer.
痛苦。有些人将其比作被大锤击中的力量。此外，对于自杀理论的怀疑者来说，如果乔是自杀的，他的枪怎么会掉在离他身体几英尺远的地方？此外，乔那天早上还储备了他通常抽的香烟。如果他知道自己活不到抽完这些烟的时候，他为什么要这样做呢？在乔去世后的那个星期五，验尸官办公室接到了一个隐藏号码的电话。这名匿名男性来电者自称是一名退休的芝加哥警官。
Convinced that Joe Glynowitz had shot himself, the caller threatened to violently harm the coroner and one of the task force investigators, unless Joe's death was declared a suicide. The call was traced back to 54-year-old Joseph Betaglia, a divorced father of three who retired from the force in 2012. Further investigation revealed he'd also called various media outlets in a bid to spread the suicide story. Bataglia was ultimately charged with disorderly conduct. He pleaded guilty and was sentenced to one year of supervision, marking the second conviction in the joke in a witch investigation that had nothing to do with the crime itself.
这名来电者坚信乔·格林诺维茨是自杀的，他威胁说，除非乔的死被宣布为自杀，否则将对验尸官和特别工作组的一名调查员进行暴力伤害。该电话被追查到54岁的约瑟夫·贝塔利亚（Joseph Betaglia），他是一位离异的三孩父亲，于2012年从警队退休。进一步调查显示，他还曾致电多家媒体，试图散布自杀的故事。贝塔利亚最终被控扰乱治安。他认罪并被判处一年监管，这标志着在乔·格林诺维茨调查案中，第二次定罪与犯罪本身无关。
Regardless, the coroner made a public statement on television, declaring, I can't rule out a suicide, I can't rule out an accident, I can't rule in a homicide, I can't issue a manner of death until law enforcement gives me everything they have. The Glynowitz family was outraged at the implication. According to them, Joe had never had a single suicidal thought in his life. Joe had been set to retire in the months leading up to his death, but had recently applied for various police-treat positions. The fact that he was planning for the future proved to them that he wasn't
无论如何，验尸官在电视上发表了一份公开声明，宣称：“我不能排除自杀，我不能排除意外，我不能断定是谋杀，在执法部门给我他们所拥有的一切之前，我不能发布死亡方式。”格林诺维茨一家对这一暗示感到愤怒。据他们说，乔一生中从未有过任何自杀念头。乔在去世前的几个月里本已准备退休，但最近申请了各种警察相关的职位。他正在为未来做计划这一事实向他们证明，他并没有
planning to take his own life. Joe's wife Melody told Cromwatch Daily, There were things that were happening in our life that people who were going to commit suicide would never do. We lived for these things. She said she wholeheartedly believed that her husband was murdered. The Glenowitz family called the suicide allegations disrespectful, hurtful, and irresponsible. They, along with the investigators, slammed the
打算结束自己的生命。乔的妻子梅洛迪（Melody）告诉《克罗姆沃奇日报》（Cromwatch Daily）：“我们的生活中发生了一些事情，那些打算自杀的人永远不会做这些事。我们为这些事情而活。”她说，她全心全意地相信她的丈夫是被谋杀的。格林诺维茨一家称自杀指控是不尊重、伤人和不负责任的。他们和调查人员一起抨击了
coroner for his statement, with the release of sensitive information putting the entire case at risk. Joe's son, DJ, told the Arlington Heights Daily Herald. I know my father, my family knows my father, and his closest friends know him well. He's not someone who ever contemplated suicide. He never had suicidal tendencies or anything like that. That's just a rumor and that's that. But there was something else raising questions. When Joe Glynawitz's body was found, an examination of his mobile phone revealed that all of his text messages had been deleted.
验尸官的声明，称泄露敏感信息使整个案件处于危险之中。乔的儿子DJ告诉《阿灵顿高地每日先驱报》（Arlington Heights Daily Herald）：“我了解我的父亲，我的家人了解我的父亲，他最亲密的朋友也很了解他。他不是那种会考虑自杀的人。他从来没有任何自杀倾向或类似的事情。那只是谣言，仅此而已。”但还有其他事情引起了疑问。当乔·格林诺维茨的尸体被发现时，对他手机的检查显示，他所有的短信都被删除了。
Investigators were growing more confused about what to make of it all. With the days passing with no breakthroughs in the case, they sent Joe's phone to the FBI. In late October, a 6,500-page report came back. All of Joe's text messages had been successfully retrieved. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. As supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. In March of 2014, a new village administrator named Anne Marin was appointed to Fox Lake. Anne had years of experience in the government sector, including public finance, and a large
调查人员对这一切感到越来越困惑。随着日子一天天过去，案件仍无突破，他们将乔的手机送到了联邦调查局（FBI）。10月下旬，一份6500页的报告出炉了。乔所有的短信都已成功找回。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供优质内容。2014年3月，一位名叫安妮·马林（Anne Marin）的新村行政官被任命到福克斯湖（Fox Lake）。安妮在政府部门拥有多年经验，包括公共财政，而她工作的一大部分
part of her job was to focus on the village budget. This also prompted a change in the village's leadership. Text records revealed that this presented an ongoing problem for Joe Glenowicz. He viewed N Marin as a power monger who was trying to control everything in the village. He soon started making inquiries about whether it was possible to separate his explorers post from the Fox Lake Police Department and to another sponsor. In March 2015, Joe texted a higher up contact saying, between you and I, I'm having a great deal of problems with our new Village Administrator.
是专注于村庄预算。这也促使了村庄领导层的更迭。短信记录显示，这对乔·格林诺维茨来说是一个持续存在的问题。他认为安妮·马林是一个权力狂，试图控制村里的一切。他很快开始打听是否有可能将他的“探索者”项目（Explorers post）从福克斯湖警察局分离出来，并转给另一个赞助商。2015年3月，乔给一位高层联系人发短信说：“你我之间，我和我们的新村行政官之间有很多问题。”
I've had a talk with the chief and he agrees with me. We are all looking at our PD retirement options and I need to move the post out of that spin of control at least till this person's contract is up. Joe's contact advised that the explorers at least till this person's contract is up. Joe's contact advised that the explorers didn't need to be charded by the village, and suggested he contact another organization that might be interested in sponsoring the program. Texts indicated that Joe put wheels in motion to make this change, but it was shut down
“我和局长谈过了，他同意我的看法。我们都在考虑我们的警察局退休方案，我需要把这个项目从那个人的控制下移走，至少要等到这个人的合同期满。”乔的联系人建议，探索者项目不需要由村里资助，并建议他联系另一个可能有兴趣赞助该项目的组织。短信显示，乔采取了行动来促成这一改变，但被
by officials. In mid-April, he texted his wife Melody to complain about Anne Marin. Joe wrote, As long as we are sponsored by the PD, and after she makes the village structure change, she will have the means and ability to do as she wishes. Melody responded, maybe we need to hide the funds somehow. A month later, Joe once again texted Melody to air his grievances about Marin, writing, she hates me and I've never said more than three sentences to her in the year she's been here.
官员们阻止了。4月中旬，他给妻子梅洛迪发短信抱怨安妮·马林。乔写道：“只要我们由警察局赞助，在她进行村庄结构调整后，她将有手段和能力做她想做的事。”梅洛迪回答说：“也许我们需要以某种方式隐藏资金。”一个月后，乔再次给梅洛迪发短信表达他对马林的不满，写道：“她讨厌我，而她在这一年里，我跟她说过的话不超过三句。”
She hates the Explorer program and is crawling up my ass. If she gets a hold of the checking account, I'm pretty well fucked. Melody responded. Hopefully she decides to get a couple of drinks in her and she gets a DUI. Joe texted back. Trust me, I've thought through many scenarios, from planting things, to vollo bog.
“她讨厌探索者项目，而且总是找我麻烦。如果她掌握了支票账户，我就彻底完了。”梅洛迪回答说：“希望她决定多喝几杯，然后酒驾。”乔回信说：“相信我，我想过很多方案，从栽赃陷害，到沃洛沼泽（Volo bog）。”
For investigators, these text messages raised some serious concerns. When they'd first searched Joe Glynowitz's desk following his death, they found a small package of cocaine in an unmarked evidence bag. It couldn't be linked to any active case. With the Jo's talk of planting things, investigators wondered if he intended to use this against Anne Marin. But this wasn't quite as concerning as Joe's mentioned of the Volo bog.
对于调查人员来说，这些短信引起了一些严重的担忧。当他们在乔·格林诺维茨死后第一次搜查他的办公桌时，他们在一个未标记的证据袋中发现了一小包可卡因。它无法与任何正在进行的案件联系起来。鉴于乔谈到“栽赃陷害”，调查人员想知道他是否打算用这个来对付安妮·马林。但这并不像乔提到的沃洛沼泽那样令人担忧。
The natural area, just four miles south of Fox Lake, contained an extensive system of waterways known as the Cheno Lakes. Joe's reference raised the question of whether he was referring to the bog as a potential dumping ground for a body. This wasn't a far-fetched possibility. Investigators extracted a private Facebook conversation between Joe and another woman, in which Joe said he was being forced to retire by the village administrator. He wrote, work has been a living hell the last two months, close to entertaining a meeting with a mutual acquaintance of ours with the word white in their nickname. Investigators believed they knew exactly who Joe was referring to, a higher ranking member of an outlaw motorcycle gang. They questioned the woman Jo was messaging. She confirmed that Jo discussed the possibility of hiring someone to conduct a hit. A meeting was arranged between law enforcement and the
这个自然区域位于福克斯湖以南仅四英里处，包含一个被称为切诺湖（Cheno Lakes）的广阔水道系统。乔的提及引发了一个问题，即他是否将沼泽视为处理尸体的潜在场所。这并非遥不可及的可能性。调查人员提取了乔与另一名女性之间的私人Facebook对话，乔在对话中说他被村行政官强迫退休。他写道：“过去两个月，工作简直是人间地狱，我差点就要和我们的一位共同熟人见面了，他们的昵称里有‘白色’（white）这个词。”调查人员认为他们确切地知道乔指的是谁，即一个非法摩托车帮派的高层成员。他们询问了与乔发信息的那个女人。她证实乔讨论过雇人实施谋杀的可能性。执法部门与
gang member thought to be the person referred to as White. White admitted he was familiar with Lieutenant Jo Glinnerwicz, but firmly denied that Joe had ever approached him about a contract killing. When Ian Marin was told about the recovered text messages, she was astonished. Her conversations with Joe had always been pleasant, and she had no reason to think there was any bad blood between them. Investigators could find no further evidence to suggest that Joe had seriously considered hiring a hitman to remove Marin from the equation.
被认为是“白色”的那名帮派成员之间安排了一次会面。白色承认他认识乔·格林诺维茨中尉，但坚决否认乔曾就雇凶杀人一事接触过他。当安妮·马林被告知恢复的短信时，她感到非常震惊。她与乔的谈话一直很愉快，她没有理由认为他们之间有什么积怨。调查人员找不到进一步的证据表明乔曾认真考虑过雇佣杀手来除掉马林。
It was possible his comments were just a distasteful attempt at dark humor. Regardless, Joe's intense dislike for the new village administrator raised the obvious question. What was he trying to hide? As a police lieutenant, Joe Glinnerwitz received an annual salary of $96,000. However, photos posted to his social media accounts suggested he lived a more lavish lifestyle than his salary would support, with vacations to Hawaii and frequent dinners at upscale restaurants. Text messages recovered from Joe's phone indicated exactly where this money was coming from. On June 22, 2015, Joe messaged his wife Melody to say,
他的评论可能只是令人反感的黑色幽默尝试。无论如何，乔对新村行政官的强烈厌恶引发了一个显而易见的问题。他到底在试图隐藏什么？作为一名警察中尉，乔·格林诺维茨的年薪为96,000美元。然而，发布在他社交媒体账户上的照片显示，他的生活方式比他的薪水所能支撑的要奢华得多，包括去夏威夷度假和经常在高档餐厅用餐。从乔手机中恢复的短信准确地指出了这笔钱的来源。2015年6月22日，乔给他的妻子梅洛迪发信息说：
used the Explorer account for flight $624.70. It can wait for a while. Their account is sitting at $3,000ish now. A few days later, a frantic Joe texted his son DJ about unidentified expenses totalling over $2,000. You are borrowing from that other account, Joe wrote, when you get back you'll have to start dumping money into that account or you will be visiting me in jail. The next day he texted DJ again, saying, I'm sticking my neck out there. He mentioned thousands of dollars he delent DJ to fix his truck and pay for a summer vacation. According to Joe, this meant there wasn't enough money left in the explorer's account
“用了探索者账户支付了624.70美元的机票。它可以等一会儿。他们的账户现在大约有3000美元。”几天后，惊慌失措的乔给他的儿子DJ发短信，提到总额超过2000美元的未明支出。“你在借用那个账户的钱，”乔写道，“当你回来时，你必须开始往那个账户里存钱，否则你就会在监狱里见到我。”第二天，他又给DJ发短信说：“我正在冒着风险。”他提到了他借给DJ数千美元来修理他的卡车和支付暑假费用。据乔说，这意味着探索者账户里没有足够的钱
to pay for upcoming expenses. He needed DJ to pay the money back so that if anyone asked, he could explain that explorer participants were given loans from time to time. Joe wrote, this villager administrator hates me and the Explorer program. This situation right here would give her the means to crucify me if it were discovered. Shortly before Joe's death, Fox Lake Police Chief Michael Bayon retired from the force pending an investigation into the department's handling of an unrelated incident. The change in leadership prompted a review of the department's procedures and equipment. On August 31, 2015, the day before Joe's death, Ann Marin paid a visit to the Explorer Post.
来支付即将到来的费用。他需要DJ把钱还回来，这样如果有人问起，他可以解释说探索者参与者不时会获得贷款。乔写道：“这个村行政官讨厌我和探索者项目。如果被发现，眼下的这种情况会给她提供钉死我的手段。”在乔去世前不久，福克斯湖警察局局长迈克尔·拜恩（Michael Bayon）因一项针对该部门处理一起无关事件的调查而从警队退休。领导层的变动促使对该部门的程序和设备进行了审查。2015年8月31日，即乔去世的前一天，安妮·马林拜访了探索者项目部。
After a year and a half in the Village Administrator role, she still didn't know how much money the Explorer program brought in. For insurance purposes, she also needed an inventory of all the Explorer's assets. The clubhouse in the basement of the community centre was packed full of cardboard boxes. Looking through them, Marin was shocked to discover that they held a visual military gear, including gas masks, bulletproof vests, combat boots, gun belts, and manuals on SWAT tactics and sniper training. This was the kind of equipment reserved for experienced police departments, not teenagers.
在担任村行政官一年半后，她仍然不知道探索者项目带来了多少钱。出于保险目的，她还需要一份探索者所有资产的清单。社区中心地下室的俱乐部会所里堆满了纸板箱。马林翻看这些箱子时，震惊地发现里面装满了军事装备，包括防毒面具、防弹背心、作战靴、枪套，以及关于特警战术和狙击手训练的手册。这是留给经验丰富的警察部门的装备，而不是青少年。
In fact, some of the most bonafired police departments couldn't even get their hands on this type of gear. Marin approached a Joe Glenowitz and requested that he provide her with a full inventory by 2pm that day. She told him, I want your invoices, your procurement, where your authorization came from. Joe responded, yes, ma'am. He then texted former police chief Michael Bayon. She has now demanded a complete inventory of explorer central and a financial report. Fuck my life. The truth was, it was impossible for Joe to provide Anne Marron with the documentation
事实上，一些最正规的警察部门甚至无法获得这种装备。马林找到乔·格林诺维茨，要求他在当天下午2点前提供一份完整的清单。她告诉他：“我要你的发票、你的采购记录，以及你的授权来源。”乔回答说：“是的，长官。”然后他给前警察局长迈克尔·拜恩发了短信：“她现在要求提供探索者中心的完整清单和财务报告。去他妈的生活。”事实是，乔不可能向安妮·马林提供她所要求的文档，
she had requested, because he'd obtained the gear fraudulently. Joe had forged the chief signature to obtain the gear from an Army surplus program, knowing it wasn't supposed to be used with the explorers. But that wasn't supposed to be used with the explorers. But that wasn't all. A deep dive into Joe Kalinerwitz' financial records revealed that for the past seven years, he had spent tens of thousands of dollars of the explorer's money to bankroll his own personal expenses. Joe had used the account to pay for everything from his mortgage to gym memberships to online pornography.
因为他是通过欺诈手段获得这些装备的。乔伪造了局长的签名，从军队剩余物资项目中获得了这些装备，明知它不应该用于探索者项目。但这还不是全部。对乔·格林诺维茨财务记录的深入调查显示，在过去的七年里，他花费了数万美元的探索者资金来资助他自己的个人开支。乔利用该账户支付了从抵押贷款到健身房会员资格再到在线色情内容的一切费用。
He used it for travel expenses, coffee, and to pay over 400 restaurant bills. With all this new evidence coming to light, investigators had no doubt about it. Joe Glinnerwitz feared his time was up. He likely believed he had two options, be exposed for embezzling charitable funds, or go out a hero. If Joe was going to pull his plan off, he knew that everything needed to play out exactly like a regular day. Therefore on the morning of September 1, 2015, he drove to the gas station to buy his usual supply of cigarettes before heading out to the area surrounding the old concrete factory. It was a location Joe knew well, having facilitated sniper training for the explorers out in
他用它支付差旅费、咖啡，并支付了400多笔餐厅账单。随着所有这些新证据的浮出水面，调查人员对此毫无疑问。乔·格林诺维茨担心他的时间不多了。他可能认为他有两个选择：要么因挪用慈善资金而被曝光，要么以英雄的身份死去。如果乔要实施他的计划，他知道一切都需要像平常一样进行。因此，在2015年9月1日早上，他开车去加油站购买了他通常抽的香烟，然后前往旧混凝土工厂周围的区域。这是一个乔非常熟悉的地方，因为他曾为探索者项目在森林环境中进行过狙击手训练。他到达现场，花了30分钟布置犯罪现场。这是他作为探索者项目的一部分以前做过很多次的事情。然后他用无线电呼叫调度员，编造了一个关于追捕三名可疑男子的故事。在呼叫增援后，他从枪套中取出枪，射击了自己的臀部，知道这不会致命。这一枪会非常痛苦，但如果有人要相信他的故事，这是必要的。
the forested surroundings. He arrived at the site and spent the next 30 minutes staging a crime scene. It was something he'd done many times before as part of the Explorer program. He then radioed the dispatcher and fabricated the story about chasing three suspicious males. spatcher and fabricated the story about chasing three suspicious males. After calling for backup, he took his gun out of his holster and shot himself in the hip, knowing it wouldn't be fatal. The shot would have been incredibly painful, but necessary if anyone was going to believe his story.
乔随后向下射击自己的防弹背心，故意击中肺动脉，但避开了心脏。这会给他长达两分钟的时间，直到流血致死。这足够让乔把枪扔在两棵树之间，然后蹒跚走开，以拉开自己与武器的距离。经过九周的调查，乔治·法兰科（George Falanco）指挥官在新闻发布会上宣布，乔·格林诺维茨中尉的谋杀案根本不是谋杀，而是一起精心策划的自杀。
Joe then shot himself downwards into his bullet-proof vest, purposely hitting the pulmonary artery, but avoiding his heart. This would have given him up to two minutes before bleeding to death. Enough time for Joe to throw his gun between the two trees, and to then stumble away to create distance between himself and the weapon. After nine weeks of investigation, Commander George Falanco fronted a press conference to announce that the murder of Lieutenant Joe Glenowitz hadn't been a murder at all, but a carefully staged suicide.
法兰科说：“我们已经确定，这起策划的自杀是格林诺维茨一直在犯下的广泛犯罪行为的最终结果。没有赢家。格林诺维茨对他所服务的公民和整个执法界进行了终极背叛。他的行为事实证明，他多年来的行为方式与他所塑造的形象完全相反。”聚集的媒体成员感到愤怒。由于自杀从一开始就被提及为一种可能性，他们想知道为什么花了两个多月的时间进行谋杀调查。他们觉得公众被愚弄了。
Falanco said, We have determined this staged suicide was the end result of extensive criminal acts that Glinnerwitz had been committing. There are no winners. Glinnerwitz committed the ultimate betrayal to the citizens he served and the entire law enforcement community. The facts of his actions prove he behaved for years in a manner completely contrary to the image he portrayed. Members of the gathering media were outraged. With suicide mentioned as a possibility from early on, they wanted to know why over two months had been spent on a homicide investigation. They felt the public had been joked.
法兰科指挥官向他们保证，调查小组确实相信他们正在调查一起谋杀案，并且在发现真相时同样感到震惊。格林诺维茨一家发表声明，要求保护隐私，称这些发现带来了又一个充满深切悲痛的日子，因为他们正在应对失去一位敬爱的父亲和丈夫的痛苦。公众并没有那么安静。在乔去世后，一个协助因公殉职警官幸存者的非营利组织曾向格林诺维茨一家捐赠了15,000美元。
Commander Filenca assured them that the investigation team had genuinely believed that they were looking at a homicide and were equally shocked to discover the truth. The Glenowitz family issued a statement requesting privacy, saying that the findings had brought another day of deep sorrow as they coped with the loss of a beloved father and husband. The public weren't so quiet. In the wake of Joe's death, a non-profit organization that assists survivors of officers killed in the line of duty had donated $15,000 to the Glenoweth family.
该组织要求退还这笔钱。摩托罗拉解决方案公司（Motorola Solutions）也撤回了他们50,000美元的信息悬赏金，但表示他们将把这笔钱捐给正在努力接受乔去世现实的探索者们。乔的一位忠实学员的母亲说：“你从来没想过他是这种人。”这对当地人产生了毁灭性的影响，一名男子告诉媒体：
The group asked for the money back. Motorola Solutions also withdrew their $50,000 reward for information, but said they would instead donate it to the explorers, who were grappling to come to terms with the reality of Joe's death. The mother of one of Joe's devoted trainees said, You never thought he was this kind of man. It had a crushing effect on locals, with one man telling the press,
“这让我心碎。”乔死亡的谜团结束了，但这并不一定意味着案件已经结案。从短信和其他证据来看，调查人员很清楚梅洛迪知道她的丈夫在挪用探索者资金。梅洛迪承认乔有时会从探索者账户中拿钱，但她坚称这些资金总是被还清的。她说她不知道她的丈夫在混用资金，并否认有任何
It's breaking my heart. The mystery of Joe's death was over, but that didn't necessarily mean that the case was closed. From the text messages and other evidence, it was clear to investigators that Melody knew her husband was misappropriating the explorer funds. Melody admitted that Joe sometimes took money from the explorer's account, but she insisted that those funds were always paid back. She said she had no idea that her husband was co-mingling funds and denied having any
参与。法务会计师未能找到明确的联系来证明梅洛迪直接对任何交易负责。无论如何，在2016年1月下旬，梅洛迪被控六项罪名，包括洗钱和未经授权且为个人利益散布慈善资金。她在缴纳50,000美元保释金后获释，她的律师发表声明称：“梅洛迪在过去几个月里遭受了巨大的痛苦，并继续带领她的家人在2015年9月1日的情感创伤事件后向前迈进。”
pardon it. A forensic accountant failed to find a clear link to prove that Melody was directly responsible for any of the transactions. Regardless, in late January 2016, Melody was indicted on six counts, including money laundering and dispersing charitable funds without authority and for personal benefit. She was released after posting a $50,000 bond with the statement released by her lawyer declaring, Melody has suffered greatly over the past few months and continues to move her family forward
考虑到梅洛迪与执法部门的合作，她对提起诉讼的决定感到震惊。梅洛迪是她丈夫秘密行为的受害者，并期待着她的法庭审判，向世界展示她的清白。2022年2月，梅洛迪·格林诺维茨承认犯有一项欺诈行为的重罪，以换取撤销所有其他指控。然而，她告诉法庭：
after the emotionally traumatizing events of September 1, 2015. Considering Melody's cooperation with law enforcement, she is devastated by the decision to bring charges against her. Melody is a victim of her husband's secret actions and looks forward to her dang court to show the world her innocence. In February 2022, Melody Glynowitz pleaded guilty to one felony count of deceptive practices in exchange for all other charges being dropped. However, she told the court,
“我想明确一点，无论报道怎么说，我从未从探索者基金中拿过一分钱。”法官判处她24个月缓刑，称她的罪行毫无疑问。乔的儿子DJ没有受到任何指控，因为无法确定DJ在父亲要求他还钱之前知道这些资金是被盗的。
I want to make it clear I never took a cent from the explorer fund, no matter what's being reported. The judge sentenced her to 24 months of probation, saying there was no question as to her guilt. No charges were laid against a Joe's son, DJ, as it couldn't be ascertained that DJ knew the funds were stolen until after his father demanded he paid the money back.
州检察官说：“整件事对福克斯湖村来说是一段悲伤而悲惨的传奇。我希望我们能够结束这一不幸的篇章，并继续致力于确保一个专业、透明且致力于福克斯湖公民的警察部门。”在乔自杀的真相曝光后，福克斯湖探索者项目暂时解散。据《芝加哥论坛报》（Chicago Tribune）报道，该项目被揭露管理极其混乱，一些成年志愿者甚至没有接受过背景调查或培训。
The state attorney said, this entire matter has been a sad and tragic saga for the village of Fox Lake. My hope is that we will be able to close this unfortunate chapter and move forward with ensuring a professional and transparent police department dedicated to the citizens of Fox Lake. After the truth about Joe's suicide was exposed, the Fox Lake explorers temporarily disbanded. According to the Chicago Tribune, the program was revealed to have been so poorly mismanaged that some adult volunteers had an even undergone background checks or training.
军事化的方式和对强力武器的使用也直接违反了童子军的规定，一些学员有时被付钱指挥交通和进行安全保卫工作也是如此。这太成问题了，以至于从头开始重新建立该项目比试图解决这些问题更容易。许多在乔·格林诺维茨指导下受训的探索者们难以理解关于他们崇敬的领导者的真相。一位在乔手下受训了六年的年轻女性告诉CNN：“你不知道该有什么感觉。你感到非常愤怒，感到非常被背叛。”
The military style approach and use of forceful weapons was also in direct violation of Boy Scout regulations, as was the fact that some trainees were sometimes paid to direct traffic and conduct security detailing. It was so problematic that it was easier to start the program from scratch than try to fix the issues. Many of the explorers who were trained under Joe Glenowitz struggled to comprehend the truth about their revered leader. A young woman who had trained under Joe for six years told CNN. You don't know how to feel. You feel so pissed off and you feel so betrayed.
“你不明白这一点。这让你很难想念他。”但受苦的不仅仅是探索者。据《每日先驱报》（Daily Herald）报道，寻找乔的假杀手花费了超过30万美元的加班费和其他费用。乔关于他的伪攻击者之一是一名黑人的谎言也加剧了福克斯湖社区持续存在的种族紧张局势，在那里黑人是少数群体。当地黑人居民弗农·兰道夫三世（Vernon Randolph III）声称，乔·格林诺维茨因他的种族对他进行了长达一年的骚扰。在乔自杀后，
You don't understand it. That makes it very difficult to miss him. But the explorers weren't the only ones who suffered. According to the Daily Herald, the hunter find Joe's fake killers cost more than $300,000 in overtime and other costs. Joe's lie about one of his pseudo-attackers being a black man also fueled ongoing racial tensions in the Fox Lake community, where black people were a minority. Local black resident Vernon Randolph III claimed that Joe Glynowitz had been harassing him for a year due to his race. After Joe killed
调查人员搜查了弗农的家，提取了他的DNA，并据称用枪指着他三岁的孩子，这些行为导致弗农持续焦虑。他向警察局提起了联邦诉讼，声称乔·格林诺维茨将他和他非裔美国同胞置于危险之中。该诉讼最终以65,000美元在庭外和解，尽管该部门否认有任何不当行为。在乔去世后，福克斯湖警察局外建立了一个纪念碑，上面挂着一张显示乔面孔的横幅，上面写着：“被铭记的英雄，永不消逝。”
himself, investigators searched Vernon's house, took his DNA, and allegedly pointed a gun at his three-year-old child, actions that caused Vernon ongoing anxiety. He filed a federal lawsuit against the police department, claiming that Joe Glynowitz put a target on his back and of his fellow African Americans. The lawsuit was eventually settled outside of court for $65,000, although the department denied any wrongdoing. In the wake of Joe's death, a memorial had been established outside the Fox Lake Police Department with a banner displaying Joe's face, along with the words, A hero remembered, never dies.
当他自杀的真相被揭露时，破坏者迅速修改了标志，在乔的额头上画了一个“L”（Loser，失败者），并将文字改为：“被遗忘的英雄。”其他支持乔的标志也被从村庄周围移除，文字“GI Joe”被改为“GI Joe”（暗示其虚假）。乔治·法兰科指挥官告诉CNN：“乔·格林诺维茨玷污了他宣誓维护的东西。他不仅背叛了我们的职业，
When the truth about his suicide was revealed, Vandals quickly altered the sign, drawing an L on Joe's forehead and changing the words to read. A hero forgotten. Other signs in support of Joe were removed from around the village, with the words GI Joe changed to GI Joe. Commander George Filenco told CNN. Joe Glynowitz dishonored what were your swore and oath to uphold. He betrayed not only our profession,
而且背叛了他的整个社区。这是我职业生涯中第一次可以真正告诉你，我为自己是一名警察感到羞耻。”走进90年代音乐产业的阴影世界，通过Casefile Presents，我们带您深入天鹅绒绳索之后，探索好莱坞俱乐部场景的阴暗面，以及统治它的夜生活国王和王后。一个秘密像货币一样交易的世界，其中最引人注目的谜团之一是：谁谋杀了布雷特·坎特（Brett Cantor）？
but his entire community. It was the first time I could actually tell you in my entire career that I felt ashamed to be a police officer. Step inside the shadowy world of the 90s music industry, with Casefowl presents, we take you behind the velvet ropes to explore the dark side of the Hollywood club scene, and the nightlife king and queen pins who ruled it. A world where secrets trade hands like currency, among one of the most compelling mysteries, is who murdered Brad Cantor.
布雷特·坎特是1992年音乐界的一颗冉冉升起的新星，担任圣诞音乐公司（Christmas Music）的A&R主管，并发现了像“暴力反抗机器”（Rage Against the Machine）这样的乐队。25岁时，布雷特的生命正处于巅峰。他是好莱坞顶级推广人，臭名昭著的夜总会Dragonfly的合伙人，并正在与女演员罗斯玛·高文（Rosemar Gowen）约会。但命运弄人，意想不到的事件将布雷特引向了一条危险的道路。1993年7月30日，布雷特的快节奏生活发生了悲剧性的转折。当他
Brad Cantor was a rising star in the music industry in 1992 as an A&R executive at Christmas Music and for discovering bands like Rage Against the Machine. By the age of 25, Brad's life was hitting all the right notes. He was the top promoter in Hollywood, a partner in the infamous nightclub Dragonfly, and was dating actress Rosemar Gowen. But his fate would have it. Unexpected events led Brett down a dangerous path. On July 30, 1993, Brett's life in the fast lane took a tragic turn. When he was
被发现死在他西好莱坞的公寓里时，他的案件至今仍未解决。加入我们，我们将揭示我们对布雷特·坎特最后日子、谋杀案及其家人和朋友记录的令人难忘的后果进行的三年冷案调查结果。“我最后一次见到布雷特·阿莱格（Brett Alague）时，他很奇怪。他剪掉了所有的头发，改变了造型，表现得也不一样了。他知道出事了。我认为那不是迈克尔·道格拉斯（Michael Douglas）的房子，海蒂（Heidi）扔了它。”
found murdered in his West Hollywood apartment, his case remains unsolved to this day. Join us as we reveal the findings of our three-year cold case investigation into Brett Cantor's final days, murder, and the haunting aftermath documented by his family and friends. The last time I saw Brett Alague, he was weird. He cut all his hair off and he changed his look and he acted different. He knew something was up. And I think it wasn't Michael Douglas's house and Heidi threw it.
“我当时每个人都在那里，从杰克·尼科尔森（Jack Nicholson）到我想是王子（Prince）和麦当娜（Madonna），这简直太疯狂了。我的大脑一片混乱，我回到家，收到一条信息说，在凶杀部门见我们。这是我打电话告诉你我们的合伙人，布雷特·坎特，然后他说，昨晚被谋杀了。”
I got everyone was there from Jack Nicholson to I think Prince of Madonna, it was just insane. My mind was in such a days that I got home and I got a message saying, meet us at the homicide department. Here's I'm calling to tell you our partner, Brett Kinner, and then he said, was murdered
“我看到这张布雷特的照片在屏幕上闪过，他们正在谈论OJ·辛普森（OJ Simpson）审判以及科尔（Cole）和罗恩（Ron），我当时想，等等，什么？我知道与那些隐藏并拥有许多触角的强大人物打交道是什么感觉。他们就像九头蛇，他们扭曲权力来看看他们是否需要。显然，南萨夸诺（South Zacuano）知道凶手是谁。南萨夸诺的复仇，南萨夸诺的某种信息为我杀人。”这是一部你永远不会忘记的摇滚真实犯罪故事。
last night. I saw this picture of Brett flash on the screen and they were talking about OJ Simpson trial and Cole and Ron and I was like, wait, what? I know what it's like to deal with powerful people that hide and have many, many tentacles. They're like hydra and they twist power to see if they're in need. Apparently, South Zacuano, who the killers were. The South Zacuano revenge, the South Zacuano's certain message killed for me. This is one rock and roll true crime story you will never forget.
《Dragonfly：布雷特·坎特谋杀之谜》，将于2023年7月18日首播。你 本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Dragonfly, the Brett Cantor Murder Mystery, premiering on July 18, 2023. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《蜻蜓：布雷特·坎特谋杀之谜》将于2023年7月18日首播。目前本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。